normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government a
tweet from Chris pavlovski the CEO of
Rumble says truth social just filed an
unprecedented defamation lawsuit
incorporating 20 media companies The
Tide is finally turning corporate media
and activists are going to feel the heat
I want you this Thursday when you're
sitting down with your family to say I'm
thankful for the lawsuits that are being
filed against these evil neocon NE
organizations truth social posts on
Truth they truthed today truth social
filed the defamation lawsuit that is
likely unprecedented in history
incorporating 20 Publications and even
uh and me and even more may be added all
of them published the same false
information about truth social and refus
to fully retract their stories to the
fake news outlets that think themselves
above accountability we'll see you in
court we get it right here filed 11223
this is a crazy week man in the Circuit
Court of the the 12 Judicial Court in
and for Sarasota County Florida Civil
Division Trump media and technology
versus here we go Guardian news and
media LLC Hollywood Reporter the mcache
company we have the M Miami Herold Alex
Mena Reuters News Rolling Stone nextar
media the hill deadline Hollywood aive
Capital LLC B Ben benzinga
marketwatch.com Forbes media axios The
Daily Beast company go go media doing
business as Gizmodo salon.com new New
York Daily News Newsweek MSNBC cable LLC
oh I'm sorry MSNBC cable LLC mediaite
DMG media Daily Mail and
CNBC wow wow so uh they say this number
wow this is crazy I heard this news this
case is about an unprecedented and
seemingly coordinated media campaign by
no less than 20 major Outlets to attack
Trump media they say uh by falsely
reporting that tmtg had lost $73 million
remember we heard this a few days ago oh
no look I got to tell you there's a lot
of people who will be like oh why is you
know oh oh Tim C is talking about the
story but that story came out earlier in
the day or came out yesterday the reason
is we fact check and verify things this
story came out I read it and said I'm
not going anywhere near this story yeah
and turns out once again it was fake
news this they say this number was an
utter fabrication each defendant in
apparent coordination reported the exact
same false number within approximately
20 24 hours of one another each citing
to a public Securities and Exchange
Commission filing in which the mystery
$73 million loss appears
nowhere Who start I want do you know who
originated this I I I the the fake news
no who origin because seems like it's
one of those things cuz there's no real
like journalism a lot of these um like
sites or whatever is probably just one
person started it and Rolling Stones
like okay but they're saying they all
cited an SEC filing oh so this is so but
no no no but you're right someone
checked on the actual here's here's the
big deal times V Sullivan the actual
malice standard would require for this
lawsuit to proceed the news
organizations had to know what they were
printing was false that's the actual
Mala standard now these companies are in
a serious steeming pile of donkeyish if
you know what I mean they are going to
have to argue when they cited the SEC
document they were unaware the number
did not appear in it yeah admitting in
court we did not actually read anything
we wrote they're going to have to admit
what everybody already knows which is
that they're not really journalists they
just are content creators essentially
that they don't fact Che yeah they're
just like yeah we don't that's hilarious
I mean I just saw and I rewrote it I
don't know I assumed it was true I don't
know yeah look man I mean that's crazy
let me let me give you an example I I
hope they lose there's this story um
about this kid in I think it was Vegas
who got stopped to death by a bunch of
kids yeah and so so one guy tweets 15
black kids Beat to Death beat a white
kid to death and it's not being covered
because of race blah blah blah and
everyone picks it up and so I watch the
video and sure enough there's six kids
not 15 two of them are not black uh four
maybe or maybe three we're not sure and
there's a lot more to the story than
just this people don't care about what
the they just keep retweeting the same
thing over and over again I stopped and
I said I'm not I'm not going to I'm not
going to go anywhere near this I this
this is clearly not true and I got to
the point where so many people had
published the fake news I made a segment
where I was just like dude this is fake
news yeah so yeah he should not have
been beaten to death but this is the
problem with the corporate press they
see a story and they say roll with it
here's the link not a single person read
the SEC filing I I I actually think
there's a strong possibility they knew
it was a false number and reported
anyway yeah because it helps them in
some way they're probably all like you
know what we can't have Donald Trump
getting elected I'm sure all 20 of these
organizations feel that way where if
they can get any sort of piece of
information that'll come out that'll
hurt him in any way they're like let's
get it out and they just that's the
objective is this is this is big though
too because uh truth social is under I
believe dwac yeah which is a publicly
traded company yeah so this negative
press means people probably started
selling off stock like crazy for sure
and now there's massive damages yeah
this going to be huge come on so are you
blackpilled still I mean this is this is
tremendous people are fighting back in
huge numbers it's crazy that these
businesses don't have like a fiduciary
obligation to like they're like the
actual just just keeping their own
businesses alive you know to just be
smarter than that but I don't I guess I
don't know who's running these things
because well I mean if their goal if I
mean like market watch and CNBC didn't
check on that like I understand Rolling
Stone they don't know what their head
from their ass but like CC didn't check
NBC News may as well be Media Matters
yeah NBC News has a political team that
is known no question and not is
non-controversial for making things up
in one instance they even even ran a
picture of me on the Today's Show over a
fake story it's been a long time but the
writer included a false statement and
then a bunch of other outlets like
variety and I think deadline picked the
story up cited the false News NBC within
minutes removed the false citation so it
was out of their story creating a
circular Loop of fake news with no
Source it's it's masterful what they do
and how they create fake and they
probably got away with it for so long
like they were probably doing this for
decades there must have been some sort
of for a period where like journalism
there was like legitimate like you know
journalism like the Watergate all that
stuff and then it switched over to this
slowly and nobody called the moned
forever this kind of stuff didn't is a
is a phenomenon that has arisen with the
internet with the internet like the the
as long as there was like cable news you
had your general well well the thing is
I I think about that sometimes though
because if they wanted to spread some
fake story before the internet it would
have been even harder to refute because
if that one person can't get some sort
of like you know TV show to cover them
but it wasn't as polarized and like
people weren't attacking other Americans
like that had different opinions if you
think about it like when I started like
watching news a lot was right after 9/11
right so that 911 happened and it's like
okay that's what I'm paying attention to
news and I used to watch MSNBC all the
time and from like 2001 until
2010 2009 something like that MSNBC was
perfectly it seemed perfectly normal
right like Joe Scarboro had a nighttime
show and he was a you know he was a
republican that acted like a Republican
and sounded like you know your standard
Republicans and stuff and it was in like
2010 2011 when you started when I
stopped watching MSNBC because I just
felt like it didn't have anything other
than the progressive perspective so I
think that that once the internet and
social once social media became so
popular and you had your big tech
company starting to realize and and make
moves with the
powerful you know products that they
created um I think that's when it really
started so I think I think this all ties
in with the whole social media and your
cell phone yeah probably all the whole
like C get I want to I want to give
people an example to understand why you
never talk to the Press you may have
heard uh about that famous Supreme Court
Justice who said don't talk to Cops well
don't talk to journalists either for any
reason now you can talk to a journalist
that they come from a publication that
you know as honor and integrity and and
you're a fan of that's totally fine but
any corporate mainstream press avoid a
guy named Andrew morance he is a scumbag
he is an evil lying prick who writes
fake stories for a living interviewed me
uh several years ago he took my quotes
and manipulated them to change what I
said but his argument basically is you
literally said these words didn't you I
can place them in any order I want so he
took two different quotes from like 30
minutes apart put them next to each
other to create a fake story when Vice
news took issue with the lie that he
published this is what he writes an
earlier version of this article included
a quotation from Tim pool concerning
Vice news's coverage in Ferguson the
quotation has been removed because it
contains several errors yeah it's
deceptive editing the errors were his
yeah but he made it seem like the errors
were mine so even though he lied in his
story when he got caught even when
they're forced to correct under threat
of lawsuit they still blamed me for the
fake story they wrote yeah and they
probably the language was vague enough
where they go you know maybe someone
will interpret it that we but they were
kind of making it out so when I when I
called and had my lawyer talk to them
and threatened they said what do you
mean there were quotes from Tim pool we
did remove them and they did contain
errors and we said yes the errors were
yours and they said everything we said
was factual yeah and even if they do
even if you finally get a retraction
from them at that point it's like
this is the new yor the quotes didn't
have errors in them the positioning of
the quotes created an error it's
deceptive editing you like a good
Simpsons reference it's the gummy Venus
demo ex absolutely you know it's just
like yes that's that happened and so I
told him I know you recorded the
conversation release the audio tapes
he's like no and the audio tapes prove
that he F he created a and there's I
mean there's been no shortage of people
like Dave porno all the time where
people want to interview him he goes
okay fine happy to interview just let me
record it and they go no right he go
what do you mean like I'll just I I just
want to hit record on my phone and
because
never talk to never talk to these people
on the phone they'll call you up and
they'll say hey how's it going you'll
say pretty good they like what' you have
for dinner you like uh Pizza I'm like
thanks by click then they'll write he
called me on the phone and made an and
engag in an anti-semitic screed and
you'll like no I didn't but he did
here's the phone record that proves it
yeah exactly they just lie they will lie
and then what are you supposed to do
when you sue they'll be like your honor
we had the conversation he called me
what do you want me to say thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net